As you can see here, after I've created or appended this div element to contain
all my buttons, I'm simply selecting all the divs in that parent div,
binding data corresponding to all the years, making an enter selection which
will grab me all the elements that are currently not yet on the page.
Which in this case is going to be all of them since we are near the top of our
file, and append div that has text equal to the data itself.
And as you can see here, I've moved the code that we wrote earlier up to
the top of the file to find all the years in which there was a World Cup.
So that for the buttons I don't have to hand code every year one at a time.
I can simply bind the years array to my div elements.
I've also added some CSS styling above to make the buttons somewhat pleasing.